[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now, it is my distinct pleasure
to introduce to you today's
speaker, Pierre Meystre.
Pierre is a good friend.
Pierre got his degree
in Switzerland, and then
another degree in Germany.
He came here to do a postdoc.
Then, he disappeared
back into Germany
to be part of the Max
Planck Institute in Optics.
And then, he came back, where
he's a Regents Professor, which
is the highest award that we can
bestow on any of our faculty.
He's a humbled
fellow, and I can go
on and on about all his awards.
He's, unfortunately,
just retired.
But he hasn't retired.
He's become the Chief Editor
for the American Physical
Society, which is a big deal.
If anybody's
interested in physics,
all the important things
are written there.
And today, he's going
to tell us a little bit
about the wondrous
physical world when
you go really, really small.
Pierre.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, thank you, Joaquin.
Has anybody looked at the
weather forecast for New York
today?
It's great to be in Tucson.
[LAUGHTER]
So thank you for inviting me.
And before I start,
there is one person
that Joaquin forgot
to thank for all
these extraordinary
lectures, which we have year,
after year, after year.
And it is a Joaquin Ruiz,
because none of that
would happen without him.
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you very much, Joaquin.
So this is the last lecture
of this physics series,
and I'm actually shocked
that there is still
anybody in the room, because--
[LAUGHTER]
--when I was a young, and
I would go to parties,
and suddenly some lady
would come close to me,
or people would come close
to me, and they'd go,
what do you do?
And I would say,
I'm a physicist.
They would all walk away.
[LAUGHTER]
So we had four
extraordinary lectures,
where the speakers
tried to explain
what we do to understand
what's next in physics.
And what we've seen is
that a lot of this work
is done in extraordinary
extreme conditions,
be it near a neutron
star or a black hole,
or in these extraordinary
accelerators which are built--
the LHC accelerator in Geneva.
And really, to understand what
we don't understand in physics,
or in astronomy, we
have to, very often,
go to these extraordinary
extreme conditions.
But what I'd like to do today
is to take a step back, and tell
you that things are even
extraordinary and bizarre and
strange in our everyday life.
And about 100 years ago,
very, very bright people
invented a new theory
of physics, which
is called quantum mechanics.
And I will show you that
quantum mechanics has
changed our lives completely.
And you could not live
without quantum mechanics
anymore, except you
don't know that,
or you don't care about that.
[LAUGHTER]
But the other thing,
which is really important,
is that, in addition
to changing our lives,
quantum mechanics has
forced us to change
our deep understanding
and things like,
what is reality, what is
locality, and things like that.
So let's see if it works.
I'm a theorist, I
break everything.
[LAUGHTER]
I think Keith Dienes has
told you something very, very
important about
what physicists do.
And the first thing that we
do is we try to understand,
what are the rules of the game?
What are the laws of nature?
And this is, again,
what, for instance,
we heard when we talked about
the LHC experiments, trying
to discover new particles,
stuff beyond just
than relative physics.
But there is a lot more
to physics than that.
And it's like if you play chess.
If you play chess,
it's one thing
to learn the rules of
how you move the pieces.
But if you just
learn the rules, I
can bet you I know my grandson
is going to beat the heck out
of you.
Because he's learned
more than the rules.
He's learned also strategies.
He's learned how to
exploit the rule,
how to understand their
profound implications,
and how to do stuff with that.
And this is the second
part of physics.
In parallel with the process
of discovering new laws,
we need to learn how
to use these rules,
how to understand
what they mean.
And this is a little
bit what I want
to talk about today, the
second aspect of what
makes physics so exciting.
And basically, I will talk
to you about two mysteries.
So there is a cat here.
And this cat is here for
at least three reasons.
The first one is that cats
are very mysterious animals,
and a lot of what we're going
to talk about is mysterious.
We know the Cheshire cat, which
was a very strange cat in Alice
in Wonderland.
Most of you probably also know
about the Schrodinger cat,
which is both dead and alive.
And so I thought that,
if I keep this cat here,
on some of the slides,
this cat will come back.
And this is a time when you
want to take a deep breath,
because it's going to
become really weird.
[LAUGHTER]
And I want you to think
a little bit this--
so the cat is going to help
guide us through this business.
And there are basically two
mysteries I want to talk about.
The first one is
something that you may
have heard about the bit more.
It's called wave
particle duality.
This was something
which was understood--
not understood, but studied
about 100 years ago,
90 years ago.
And basically, it tells you
that quantum objects are waves,
except if you look at them.
So that's the first mystery
we're going to talk about.
And the second mystery is
something Einstein called
spooky action at a distance.
And it has to do with the
fact that, in some situations,
you can have two particles,
one on the moon and one
on the earth, or even
more unrealistically,
one in San Francisco
and one in New York,
and you cannot describe these
two particles independently.
What a particle does profoundly
and instantaneously impacts
the other particle.
So this is the two mysteries.
And the bottom
line of my lecture
is going to be that
these two mysteries lead
to two really key consequences.
The first one is that
we have to rethink
what we mean by reality.
And the second one
is that we will
need to rethink what
we mean by locality.
Reality is the idea that the
properties of objects exist,
whether I look at them or not.
So basically, Joaquin
exists with a beard,
whether I look at him or not.
That's reality.
Locality has to do with the
fact, which Einstein made very
clear, that no information
can propagate faster
than the speed of light.
And we're going to have
to revisit these two
self-evident
truths, if you want,
in the context of
quantum mechanics.
OK.
So let's try to stop
a little bit slowly,
and it's always a good idea to
start with talking about light.
Because for
centuries, scientists
have been worried quite
a bit about light.
What is it light?
How do we process images?
All these kind of
optics of light
are extremely fascinating.
I could give a whole lecture,
or series of lectures, on that,
but I don't have time.
So I will start at Newton.
Newton was a cranky old man.
[LAUGHTER]
And he was cranky, and
he looks cranky here.
And he actually was one of
the most important scholars
of optics, until the
18th and 19th century.
He wrote a wonderful
book called Opticks,
where he studied the
reflection of light,
the refraction of light.
He studied how light, if you
put light through a prism,
it gets broken into colors.
And he came to the conclusion
that light was made out
of streams of little particles.
OK, that was his
view of the world.
So light was
particles for Newton.
And this view of
light stayed with us
for well over 100 years,
until another great character
came around.
His name is Thomas Young.
He was actually a polymath.
He was a medical doctor.
He was very
interested in the eye.
He's the first who understood
how the eye changes
its shape so that we can focus
object at different distances.
He also was the first to
understand what astigmatism is.
But in addition, he
was also an Egyptolog.
He made key development
which led then
to the translation
of the Rosetta Stone
by Champollion in France.
And so he did all
kinds of things.
He started in mechanics.
There's a wonderful book.
If you don't have anything to
do, you should read this book.
The title of the
book, Thomas Young--
The Last Man Who
Knew Everything.
An absolutely remarkable book.
And he studied life as well,
because he was interested
in the eye, so,
therefore, he thought
I need to study what light is.
And he made a very simple
experiment, which I show here,
where he took a little
screen, and he cut two slits
into this screen, and
he shone a beam of light
through that screen.
A very, very simple experiment.
And we all know what to expect
in this experiment, right?
What do we expect?
Well, light is made out
of little particles,
so the particles will
go either through one
of the slits or the other.
So we are clearly going
to get two bright lines
on some detector,
on some screen,
behind this double slit.
This is completely
obvious, right?
So why bother to
do the experiment?
But anyway, he did
the experiment anyway.
He probably didn't have
anything else to do.
And what he found is
completely different.
He found this pattern of rays,
which are called interferences.
And interferences
were well known,
and are very well
known, for instance,
if you are on a very
quiet pond, and you
throw two little
pebbles in this pond,
you'll get two waves,
which are going
to come close to each other.
And when they interact,
you get these waves.
You get this
interference pattern.
So like, on that.
So he concluded
that actually life
is not made out of particles,
but it's made of waves.
So just to make sure that
we keep that in mind,
because it will be
somewhat important.
If light is made
out of particles,
we would get a patter like
that-- two bright spots.
If it's made out of waves, we
will get something like that--
the interferences
that Young observed.
So he wrote a paper.
And then, he realized
that it's not a good idea
to contradict Newton.
[LAUGHTER]
So here is the paper.
I don't want you to
read it, but I just
want to show you a
review of his paper.
And now, I'm an editor
of a bunch of journals,
so I see reviews like that.
Maybe not as arrogant.
But to show you that physicists,
contrary to popular belief,
are not always nice guys.
So here is what
this review said--
"the paper contains nothing
that deserves the name either
of experiment or
discovery, and it
is in fact destitute of
every species of merit."
[LAUGHTER]
And then, it got personnel.
"More fancies, more
unfounded hypotheses,
more gratuitous fictions,
all upon the same field
on which Newton trod, all from
the fertile yet fruitless brain
of the same eternal Dr. Young.
[LAUGHTER]
This is not nice.
So yeah.
So it's tough, right?
You have this dogma around,
and you try to change it,
and it's really tough.
And it took a long, long time
before finally people said,
maybe Young has something.
And during the
whole 19th century,
people worked very hard at that.
And the culmination of this
work was the work of Maxwell--
James Clerk Maxwell--
who explained light
in terms of
electromagnetic waves.
I think that Keith Dienes
has talked about that.
These are electromagnetic waves
which propagate-- surprise--
at the speed of light.
OK.
So this was perfect.
And this is one of the
culminations of 19th century
physics.
It's also a boot
camp for theorists.
This is very hard
physics, and it explains
a great deal of things.
And it's wonderful.
It's wonderful, except
there was just one
small problem with
Maxwell's equations,
and this theory of light.
And this is something
called blackbody radiation.
So let me tell you what
blackbody radiation is.
Blackbody radiation has to
do with the light emitted
by something called a blackbody.
So what is a blackbody?
This is what I've
tried to show here.
It's basically a little
cavity, a hollow cavity,
which is black for everything.
So it absorbs all colors
of light perfectly.
Now, of course, if the system
wants to reach a temperature
and not melt, it has
also to emit this light.
So there is an equilibrium
between the light which
is absorbed, and the
light which is emitted.
Blackbody is that this
works for every color
in the spectrum of light.
And then, you can
make a little pinhole
and see how much
intensity you have
for different colors
of this light.
It's called the spectrum
of blackbody radiation.
And you can measure that, and
you find this result here.
So on the horizontal axis, I
have the wavelength of light.
It's just the
color of light, OK.
And on the vertical
axis, it's the intensity.
And I have three curves of
different color-- a red curve,
a yellow curve,
and a blue curve--
for three different
temperatures.
So it's 3,000 Kelvin.
You see the peak.
The most intensity is
around 1 micrometer,
which is infrared light.
As you heat up your
cavity, you make
it 4,000 Kelvin, the peak
of the intensity shifts
to more visible
light near the red.
And if it gets even warmer,
it shifts toward the blue.
These are things that people
can measure extraordinary
accurately.
This is the blackbody spectrum.
And the white curve is
the classical theory
for 5,000 Kelvin--
the theory of Maxwell.
And you don't have
to have a Nobel
Prize to see that the blue
curve and the white curve
don't quite match.
Now, physicists are
highly trained people.
We go through
undergraduate school.
We do four years of
We do a bunch of years
of graduate school.
We become postdocs.
We go through tenure
track, and all that.
So we have really very fancy
technical words to explain
these kind of problems.
OK, that's the problem, and
this is the technical word.
[LAUGHTER]
So it means we have a problem.
Everything was perfect, except
for just this one experiment.
And nobody could throw
away the blackbody,
and the experiments were very
good, and we had a problem.
So it bothered
people a great deal.
And one of the folks who
spent a lot of years trying
to figure out what was
going on was a physicist
in Germany named Max Planck.
And finally, out
of desperation, he
came out with a crazy, new
assumption based on nothing.
He said light is made of
waves, but these waves
come in little
bundles of energy,
which can have only
discrete values, which
are called quanta of energy.
He invented the word
quanta of energy.
Now, this is what we
would call photons.
It was completely
out of nowhere.
It was just desperation
he came up with this.
And then, Einstein worked
with this hypothesis.
He was able to explain
a bunch of other things.
So suddenly, we were
back in a situation,
this kind of perfect
compromise, where light
is both waves and particles.
So this was quite a big
leap of faith, in a sense,
but it explained
this blackbody system
and all kinds of other things.
And then, there was a prince.
You know, every story
has to have a prince.
So we have a French prince.
And this is Prince
Louis de Broglie.
And he went one step further.
He said, well, if
light is made out
of objects, which are
both waves and particles,
maybe everything is made
out of waves and particles,
every particle is
made out of wave--
has a wave aspect and
a particle aspect.
For instance, electrons.
And this was, again, huge.
It was his PhD thesis.
He was in his 20s, OK.
And if you did that, you could
develop some wonderful theory,
but it was again not clear that
it was right until, in 1927--
so just 90 years ago--
there were experiments
done in the United States
by Davisson and Germer, which
actually proved that electrons
behave like waves.
So all this story, which
took about 20-25 years,
lead to the development
of quantum mechanics.
There are two of
the big heroes--
Erwin Schrodinger and
Werner Heisenberg.
Now, you have to
understand, Heisenberg
was like 25 years
old when he did that.
And Schrodinger was the old guy.
He was almost 40.
Don't you hate them?
[LAUGHTER]
They have no respect.
I guess you had to be
really young to be so crazy
and create, even
invent, this new theory.
And it worked.
And quantum mechanics
has been developed
to an exquisite level
of understanding,
and it's change your life.
How has it changed your life?
If you understand
quantum mechanics,
if you understand that
electrons are waves,
you can understand why
some solids are metals,
some are insulators,
some are semiconductors,
and all kinds of
things like that.
And this led to
extraordinary development.
You would not have
integrated circuits
if you did not
understand quantum mech--
if somebody did not
understand quantum mechanics.
You would also not
have cellphones.
You would not have a GPS system.
What else would you not have?
You would not have the
internet, that's for sure.
You would not have lasers.
You would not have
laser surgery.
If you did not understand
how atoms interact
with magnetic fields,
or with light,
you would not have
magnetic resonance imaging.
Did I get it right?
I did.
And you would not
have solar panels.
So it's really
changing our life, OK?
Everything we have in this room.
I don't know how many people
have a cell phone in this room,
but I would bet
it's more than one.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is all based
on understanding
quantum mechanics, understanding
this wave particle duality.
Of course, there are
also some bad things.
And as somebody pointed
out, a single nuclear weapon
can ruin your whole day.
But anyway, so this is really
what quantum mechanics has
done for us, thanks to
people really understanding
how to play this game.
But I want to go
back a little bit,
because now we know
how to do that,
but do we understand the
real deep implications
of quantum mechanics?
And this is what I want to spend
a few minutes going back to.
So I want to go back to
this double slit experiment.
Because I told
you that electrons
are particles and
waves, or photons
are particles and waves.
But I have not told you
how strange that is.
And now I want to tell
you how strange that is,
so I'm going to redo the
Thomas Young experiment.
But instead of sending a beam
of light, or a beam of electrons
through my double
slit, I'm going
to send one electron a day.
Or maybe one one
electron every week.
Or one electron every minute.
It doesn't matter, but
very rare events, OK.
One electron, and then you wait.
And now, we can do
that, because we
have all these graduate students
who have nothing better to do.
[LAUGHTER]
So they can certainly do
this kind of experiment.
So let's see what happens.
So what do you
expect will happen?
Well, what I expect will happen
is now it's just one electron,
so the electron is going to
go through one of the holes
and land on the screen,
and I will get a little dot
on my detector.
And I do.
So this is after a week.
You have seven or eight dots.
There's no big deal here.
And then, I can
do it for a month,
and I get them more dots.
And then, I'll do it for
a year, and suddenly, wow.
I get these interferences.
This is completely crazy.
You have to understand
this is completely crazy.
Because I did it one
electron at a time.
How do they know?
Well, I'm a physicist,
so I say, well, I'm
going to trick these
darn electrons.
I'm going to check through
which hole they went.
And I can put a little detector.
So here, I have my experiment,
I put a magnifying glass--
actually, it's going to be a
slightly fancier detector--
and I'm going to just
look through which
hole this darn electron went.
We can do that.
Do the experiment.
You measure through which
hole your electrons went.
Boom.
The interferences disappear.
[LAUGHTER]
There's the cat.
What have we learned?
Is my electron a
wave or a particle?
If you look, if you
observe which way
the light went through,
of the electron,
it appears to be a particle.
If you don't look, it
behaves like a wave.
What it means is that
you can change reality
by deciding what you're
going to look at.
And this is the new thing that
quantum mechanics does for you.
It forces you to change your
understanding of reality.
John Wheeler.
You may have heard about John
Wheeler in other lectures,
because John Wheeler was a great
expert at general relativity.
He coined the word
black hole actually,
but he was also a great
expert at quantum mechanics.
And he was also a
magician with words.
And he coined this sentence
to describe the situation.
"What we call reality arises
in the last analysis from
the posing of yes or no
questions and the registering
of equipment-evoked responses--
all things physical are
information theoretic
in origin."
Here's another way
to say what he said--
no phenomenon is a
phenomenon until it
is a recorded phenomenon
brought to a close
by an irreversible
act of amplification.
It's a very, very
profound statement.
Feynman-- everybody has
heard about Feynman--
put it another way,
which is actually
very important to also digest.
"It is impossible to explain
this in any classical way.
It has in it the heart
of quantum mechanics.
In reality, it contains
the only mystery.
We cannot make the mystery
go away by explaining it.
We can just tell you how it
works, but not why it works."
So through this wave
particle duality,
which we use to make transistors
and [? RCs, ?] and all that,
has actually much more profound
implications in a sense,
because it forces us to revisit
what we mean by reality.
And the reality is that I'm
going to be in real trouble
with time.
OK.
So this was my first mystery.
Remember, I'd said I would
talk about two mysteries?
Now, I'm going to get to
the second mystery, which
Einstein--
Einstein was such
a brilliant man.
He always brought up new
extraordinary concepts.
And this is spooky
action at a distance.
So now we're going to talk about
spooky action at a distance.
And this is a bit tricky, so I
actually will need some help.
So I need two assistants.
Now, I'm not going to ask
any of you to come up there.
I don't want to
impose that on you.
So I'll have two
virtual assistants.
And in physics, we used
to call them A and B.
But then, we decided to be
nice, and we had to be friendly.
So now we call
them Alice and Bob.
So I want to introduce
you to Alice and Bob.
So who should Alice be?
I think it's pretty obvious.
Alice should be Alice
from Alice in Wonderland.
So here is Alice.
And for Bob, we
need somebody who
is a very distinguished
person, probably
someone with a Nobel Prize.
Nobel Prize gives you the kind
of gravitas that you need.
So here is a Bob
with a Nobel Prize.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is Alice and Bob.
And they will be with us
for a little while now.
So let's first do a
very simple experiment.
We're going to play with coins.
So we have a bag of coins,
and both Alice and Bob
take one coin each
out of this bag.
And then, Alice flies
fly to New York.
Bob flies to Los Angeles.
And they start
playing head and tail.
They start flipping their coin.
So let's do it once.
And Alice finds tail, Bob head.
Do it again, Alice
head, Bob tail.
Do it again, head, tail, head,
tail, tail, head, head, tail.
That's what they find.
This should bother you.
Does it bother you?
Yep.
Good.
Why does it bother you?
Because you never find a case
where they get the same thing.
These are independent coins.
He took his coin,
she took her coin.
She went to New York,
he went to Los Angeles.
There must be many
situations where they both
flip to head or to tail.
We don't have any of those here.
So this is impossible, right?
This is impossible.
It was an hour it's impossible.
But what I'm going to show
you, or try to convince you,
is that, in quantum mechanics,
this is actually possible.
Now, Alice comes and says,
"There is no use trying.
One can't believe
impossible things."
But fortunately
the Queen of Hearts
comes and answers, "I daresay
you haven't had much practice.
When I was your age, I always
did for half an hour a day.
Sometimes I've believed as
many as six impossible things
a day."
All I want you to do is to
believe one impossible thing
today.
Or maybe two.
OK, so let's try to do
some impossible stuff.
And to do that, I will
tell you something
that we can do in physics.
We can do something,
which is called--
we can create something
called two-state particles.
Let me tell you a little
bit how this works.
It's actually very
simple in principle.
In practice, only
experimentalists can do that.
But basically, the
idea is very simple.
You take a source of
atoms, maybe cesium atoms
or silver atoms, and
you put them in an oven.
And you heat them up until
they start evaporating.
And some of the atoms are
going to exit from the oven.
And then, you put
two little holes
to make a very
nice beam of atoms.
You can do that.
And then, you pass
this beam of atoms
through a magnet, which is a
north pole and a south pole.
And then, you see where these
atoms land on the screen
after the magnet.
And what you will find
is that they will only
land in two positions,
either up or down.
OK.
This is called the
Stern-Gerlach experiment.
For a given atom, you don't
it will end up or down,
but they will only
end up or down.
So this is basically like coins.
For coins, we had head and tail.
For these atoms,
we have up or down.
So in a sense, you can think
of them as quantum coins.
And one thing that
I also need to tell
you, because it's
going to be important,
is that you can rotate the
magnets, and what will happen
is that you just
rotate the same.
You still have just two dots.
They will just be
rotated like the magnet.
And we are going to use that
later to really confuse things
even more.
So these are, if you
want, our quantum coins.
And these quantum
coins are very strange.
So classical coins can
have only head or tail.
Quantum coins can have up
and down at the same time.
We talked a bit about
the Schrodinger cat,
which can be alive and dead.
Well, it's hard to make a
cat which is alive and dead.
But these quantum coins, we can
really make them up and down
at the same time.
So this is a key difference.
Classical coins have
to be head or tail,
this can be head and
tail at the same time.
So now, let's play
with these coins.
OK, let's do the Alice
and Bob experiment.
So I'm going to have a
source of these coins.
And I can send two of
them, because these
are very special sources.
You have to work a little
bit at making these sources.
But you can make these two
quantum coins, these two atoms.
You can prepare the
system in such a way
that, if the first one is
up, then the second one
is down for sure.
And if the first one is
down, then the second one
is up for sure.
You can do that
in atomic physics.
It's not very hard.
These are called
entangled particles.
If one is, the other
one is down for sure.
That's the thing that was
impossible with the coins
of Alice and Bob, but with
atoms, you can do that.
And so, if you want to
describe this system,
you will say that this system
is such that, if one is up,
the other one is down.
But remember, they can be up
and down at the same time.
So we have the system which
is up, down, and down, up.
So that's the state
of the system,
to use the jargon
of quantum physics.
These are entangled particles.
And now, let's make
some measurements.
So I'm going to make an
experiment, where I'm going
to put one of these magnets.
Remember like we had a
couple of slides ago,
I'm going to put a magnet
to try to figure out
if my particle 1 is up or down.
And let's say I measure
my particle to be up.
So what does it mean?
It means the second
particle is down for sure.
Right?
All these particles
were prepared.
So once I look, and I discover
that the first particle is up--
look under the--
poof, this disappears.
After I have measured the
state of my first particle,
the system is now in this state.
The second particle
is instantly in down.
And this will be
instantly in down,
even if the first
particle is in New York,
the second is in Los Angeles.
This is what Einstein called
spooky action at a distance.
Why did he call it spooky
action at a distance?
Because it was
this instantaneous
change in the system, and
Einstein, who was no dummy,
knew that things like
that should not happen,
because no information
can be transferred faster
than the speed of light.
So what's going on here?
What's going on is
that spooky action
at a distance conflicts with the
fundamental concept of locality
in classical physics.
And that's a problem.
That's a real problem.
Now, I have to make
a point very clear.
It doesn't mean that information
can be transferred faster
than the speed of light.
But just the state
can be changed faster
than the speed of light, which
is a different statement.
OK.
And that's not all.
He comes back.
Einstein never
stops annoying you.
[LAUGHTER]
Einstein wrote a very, very
wonderful paper in 1935
with his colleagues,
Podolsky and Rosen.
This paper made everybody think.
And it's almost certainly the
most interesting wrong paper
in the history of
physics, because it really
made everybody think.
And he had a definition of
reality, which I already hinted
at earlier, which he wrote.
His definition of reality--
"If, without in any way
disturbing a system,
we can predict with
certainty the value
of a physical quantity,
then this physical quantity
corresponds to an element
of physical reality."
So that's what I
said about the dean.
I don't have to go
touch his beard.
I know that he has a beard.
There is an element of
physical reality associated
with his beard.
It might be a poor
element of reality,
but it's an element of really.
So basically, since
now you know for sure
what the state of
this particle 2
is without having
to measure it--
just the particle that
you didn't look at--
there is an element of
physical reality associated
with the state of this particle.
No question.
But now you can become nasty.
And you say, I'm going
to do another experiment.
Instead of having my
magnets pointing vertically,
I'm going to rotate
them this way.
Same experiment,
but now I've change
the direction of the magnet.
And obviously, I can
do the same argument,
and I will also have an element
of physical reality associated
with the state of this
particle along this direction.
Makes a lot of sense.
It should, because it
comes from Einstein.
Einstein makes a lot of sense.
But then, there is this fellow
I mentioned earlier, Heisenberg.
And he said, you can't do
that, not in quantum mechanics.
This is no-no.
It's a big no-no.
It's called the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle.
It is fundamental to
quantum mechanics.
And he says that
you cannot measure--
I'll use jargon, the spin
is basically this component
of this particle up and down--
you cannot measure this thing
in a vertical and a horizontal
direction at the same time.
It is not allowed
in quantum mechanics
to do that with
arbitrary accuracy.
This is the Heisenberg
uncertainty relation.
Nobody disputes that.
It's been tested and
tested and tested.
So here is Einstein,
who says, there
must be an element of
physical reality associated
with the vertical
component, an element
of physical reality associated
with the horizontal component.
And Heisenberg says, you can't
measure both at the same time.
So what is the conclusion?
The conclusion is that
quantum mechanics does not
provide the complete
description of physical reality.
And this is the famous
Einstein-Podolsky-Rosen
paradox.
So where does it leave us?
It leave us with a problem,
which I already showed you
at the beginning of
this presentation,
that quantum entanglement
is in conflict
with two fundamental tenets
of classical physics--
reality and locality.
And we went through that.
OK, so that's pretty heavy.
It's actually too
heavy for me, so when
you see something like that--
so I have a friend who would
say, that's why we drink.
[LAUGHTER]
But another person will
say, I give up, OK?
I'm going to do something else.
I'm going to go and
start a sock factory.
So now we are going
to talk about socks.
[LAUGHTER]
That should be a bit
easier than to talk
about this darn particles.
So I'm going to work
in a sock factory,
and they want me
to test the socks--
how good they are, how well
they resist being washed at room
temperature-- you
know, cold wash--
and intermediate temperatures,
and maybe hot temperatures.
By the way, this
is a presentation
I stole from this reference.
So don't blame me.
So here's the test
we want to do--
am I losing--
OK.
Will these socks
survive 1,000 washes
at 0 degrees, 45
degrees, and 90 degrees?
But I'm a bit lazy.
I don't want to do
all these tests.
So I'm going to take some of the
socks and do them at 0 and 45.
Some I will do it 0 and 90,
and some I will do at 45 at 90.
And I figure my boss will
never see any different.
So that's what I'm going to do.
So I can do this
test, and what I
find is something which may
sound bizarre, but you will see
is actually completely trivial.
What do we find is
the number of socks
that can be washed at 0
degree and not at 45 degree
temperature, plus the number
that could be washed at 45
degrees and not
90 degrees must be
larger than the number that can
be washed at 0, but not at 90.
Sounds strange, but let me
show you why it's not strange.
I have a very beautiful little
picture here, which is actually
due to Ken and Danny.
So thank you so much
for figuring that out.
So here are my socks.
So green is they passed the
test, red they failed the test.
So let's look at the
first one, the ones which
can pass at 0 degree
and not at 45 degrees.
So we've not made the
test at 90 degree.
But at 90 degree, either
they would have passed
or they would not have passed.
So my pairs of socks on
the left are the same
as the pair on the right,
except, at 90, they might
have passed or not have passed.
OK?
And I can do the same
for the next test.
The ones that can
pass at 45 and 90--
these are these guys
here-- but the test at 0
could be successful or not.
So this is really what it means.
And the one at 0 degree is
90 degrees, same thing again.
The one in the
middle, at 45 degrees,
could have passed
or not have passed.
And now, you look at
this bunch of socks,
and you give them letters,
because we are doing science.
So we put letters.
[LAUGHTER]
And you see that these guys
here-- the guys B down here--
it's green, red, red.
It's the same as the
green, red, red up here.
And the green, green,
red are the same
as the green, green,
red up in the middle.
So you see these two guys are
included in the other two,
but the other two
have more stuff.
And therefore, what
is in the first two
is at least as much as
what is in the third.
So it actually kind
of makes sense.
And now, you can make
a great assumption,
or you can ask the question--
are particles like socks?
So you can make the same
estimation with particles.
You change socks
to little balls,
and you get exactly
the same thing.
And this is a very
fundamental theorem,
which is called Bell's theorem.
He did it with a
little bit more mass,
but basically
that's what he did.
And here is John Bell.
John Bell was an extraordinary
talented theoretical physicist.
Worked at CERN.
He was a high energy
physicist, but he also
played with these foundations
of quantum mechanics.
And the beauty of this example
with socks and particles
is that this is something that
you can test experimentally.
The EPR paradox,
for a long time,
folks thought that it was
more or less philosophy.
But now, you can test these
things experimentally.
And if the particles don't
behave like sock's, it
means something fundamental.
It means that quantum
physics cannot be represented
by a classical
picture of physics.
Or if you want to put
in more fancy words,
if this test is
failed, it rules out
of description of
quantum mechanics
by a local realistic theory.
And again, the beauty
of Bell's theorem
is that, suddenly, you can
actually do the experiment.
So the experiment was done.
Started in the late
'70s and early '80s.
And the way you do the
experiment is pretty much what
I did before, except that now,
having testing on just one
side, you put one side at 90
degrees and one at 45 degrees
to do the two temperatures if
you want the two angles now
for the spins, and you can
still do this experiment.
And you can count.
And these experiments
have been done
better and better
and better, and they
are becoming more and
more sophisticated,
and with less and
less systematic error.
And the result is, if the
particles behave like socks,
you will have this inequality.
And in quantum mechanics,
you can actually
calculate, or measure,
these probabilities,
and you'll find that
the first one is 0.07.
The second one is 0.07.
And the third is 0.25.
And 0.25 is larger than 0.14.
So this is violated.
So particles don't
behave like socks.
[LAUGHTER]
And basically, it shows that
quantum mechanics is not
a local realistic theory.
So Feynman.
Feynman is back.
And he made another
statement about the result
of this experiment, which is the
statement that you should make,
that we should all make.
This is why we drink.
[LAUGHTER]
"Quantum mechanics
describes nature as absurd
from the point of
view of common sense.
And yet it fully
agrees with experiment.
So I hope you can accept
nature as she is--
absurd."
And unfortunately, that's true.
It's completely contrary
to our common intuition.
We're just not hardwired
to understand what
nature is at the quantum level.
Now, there is another
quote I want to make.
This is from somebody
named Alain Aspect.
Alain Aspect is a remarkable
figure in this whole story,
because he started
to do experiments
as a graduate student.
I know him quite well.
And he told me that, when he
started to learn about that,
he went to visit John Bell.
Alain Aspect is in Paris,
John Bell was in Geneva.
And he told him, I
want to do experiments.
And John Bell asked him, do
you have a permanent job?
And Alain Aspect was a student.
He said, no I don't.
He said, don't do it.
Because it was the best
way not to get the job.
But Allain Aspect, being who he
is, decided to go ahead anyway.
And he's become the world
expert on this business.
I'm sure he will
get a Nobel Prize.
The other reason I want to
show this picture of Allain
is that he makes the best
duck confit in the world.
[LAUGHTER]
And he has a cellar with
over a thousand bottles.
And I want to be invited
back in his house.
[LAUGHTER]
And what Allain said is, "By
closing"-- so it was in 2015,
he said that, when these
perfect experiments
on the violation of Bellian
inequalities came out.
And Allain said, "By
closing these loopholes"--
so it was still bothering
people-- "at once,
three experimental tests of
Bell's inequalities remove
the last doubts that we should
renounce local realism."
And the other key point that he
made, that other people knew,
and this brings us to the
second quantum revolution,
is that these experiments
opened the door to new quantum
information technologies.
And I want us to spend
about three or four
minutes-- where is Bo?
Bo is checking time.
Bo, I think it's
time for a break.
So I want to show you
one simple example of how
this new, more profound,
understanding of the way
to manipulate the laws
of quantum mechanics
will lead us to
new technologies.
The example I want to mention
is quantum cryptography.
Now, we all know
about cryptography.
This is these
techniques which make
us able to communicate
with our iPhones,
without everybody
eavesdropping on us.
So the idea is--
let's say, here is Alice again.
She wants to
communicate with Bob.
She wants to send him
this beautiful message--
very romantic message-- and
she doesn't want anybody else
to hear this message.
So the way cryptography
works is that you
invent a key, which
allows you to encrypt
your system, and the keys
that she uses, in this case,
is this thing in yellow here.
And the trick is that Bob
also needs to know this key.
OK, here's the key.
And then, once he
has the key, she
can just call him
with the message.
No, first, she has to
encrypt this message.
And the way she does
it here is very simple.
If two numbers are the same, it
becomes a 0 in the encryption.
If the two numbers are
different, it becomes a 1.
And then, she sends
encrypted message.
And he uses the same rule
to recover his message.
That's how it works.
And the trick of cryptography
is to make these keys very safe,
hard to break,
and hard to steal.
But it's always a problem.
And people are
spending actually a lot
of money making safe
encryption, and trying
to break safe encryption.
So quantum entanglement
allows actually to beat this.
And the way it works
is very simple.
Instead of having a key
that you share by telephone,
or by meeting under
a tree or something,
you do an experiment with
these entangled particles.
So let's say Alice is
going to create sources
of entangled particles,
and she gets one of them,
and Bob gets the other one.
And now, they're
both going to measure
the state of their particle,
if it's up or down.
And if the analyzers-- if the
magnets are aligned the same
way, they know for
sure that, if they--
Alice knows for sure,
if she measures up,
Bob will have down.
But if they are not
aligned the same way,
then there is
nothing they can say.
They don't know what the
answer of the other will be.
So all they need to do is
to do this experiment--
this measurement--
many, many times,
and then they get on
the phone and they share
the alignments of their magnet.
And maybe they will say,
oh, in the first experiment,
both magnets were
aligned the same way.
So I know what I measured,
therefore I know what he has.
And in the second one, they
were not aligned the same way,
so we discard them.
And they keep doing, and you
keep only the results when
your magnets were aligned, so
you get your nice entanglement.
And you build a key this way.
You never have to tell the
result of your experiment.
You just have to say the
setting of your magnet.
So can you break this way
of transferring information?
It turns out--
that's what I said.
So it turns out that
you can't in principle.
And the reason you
can't is twofold.
The first one is the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle,
which we talked about.
If somebody tries to make a
measurement on your system,
it will perturb your system
in quantum mechanics.
So we'd know for sure that
somebody was eavesdropping.
So the eavesdropper
will say, well,
I'm just going to
duplicate your system.
I'm going to make a
clone of your system,
make my measurements
on your system,
and then I will know
what you have done,
and I will steal your key.
And you can't do that either.
I don't have time
to go through that.
You can't do that, because
there is a theorem, which
is called the no-cloning
theorem, which
says that you can only
duplicate the system by losing
all information.
So the result is that
quantum key distribution--
that's the best
word used for that--
is completely safe.
And this is one of
the first applications
in the second
quantum revolution.
There are several companies
which sell these systems,
to banks mostly.
There is one in Geneva.
There is one in Vienna.
There is one in New York.
And so I was talking
about that with Dean Ruiz.
And he says, that's really
cool, because now we
could have the
secret information
all around the world.
And I had to tell
him, not so fast.
Not so fast, because
it's actually hard.
And it's so hard that the
world record right now
of how far you can actually
transmit quantum information
this way is 90 miles.
And there is a dream to actually
have this global quantum
communication, but it
doesn't work so far.
And why doesn't it work?
It turns out that, if you
want to make these experiments
at very small
scales in your lab--
on the tabletop in your lab--
it's not too hard to do.
But the bigger you want
to do the experiment,
the harder it becomes.
And it may just be impossible
to do a global communication
system.
We just don't know.
So this begs actually
a couple of questions,
which bring the cat back.
So we know how to do
these quantum systems
when they are somewhat small.
140 kilometers is
not completely small,
but it's not very big either.
So this begs the
question-- why don't we
live in a quantum world?
Why does it look like
reality is the way we've--
we have this intuition for that?
If quantum theory is a
more fundamental theory
than classical theory,
why does everyday word
appear as classical?
Another related question is,
are we fooling ourselves?
Quantum mechanics was
actually developed
to describe atoms and photons
at the microscopic level.
We've pushed it very hard.
But is it really the
fundamental theory?
To which extents are
these laws applicable
in macroscopic systems?
And a related question is, are
there fundamental limitations
to quantum entanglement?
Not practical, but
fundamental limitations.
Or can we, in
principle, prepare a cat
in a state where it
is both alive and dead
at the same time?
So these are very
profound questions.
And these are questions
which bother many physicists.
And there are two
approaches to this question.
There is what is called the
shut up and calculate kind
of physicist.
This sounds pejorative,
but it's not really.
It's the way that most
physicists do physics.
We do our calculations.
We take our system that we want
to behave quantum mechanically,
but we know that
it's not isolated.
It's surrounded by
the rest of the world,
and it's always coupled somehow
to the rest of the world.
And it turns out that,
the bigger your system,
the harder it is to isolate
it from the rest of the world.
And this coupling to
the rest of the world
tends to make the systems
behave more classically.
So this is kind of
the practical-- the
shut up and calculate--
where you don't really
try to understand fundamentally
what the question might be.
And then, there are
the other physicists
who actually try to
understand this question
in a fundamental way.
And they are working very hard.
And they're also developing
experiments jointly with theory
to try to figure out if there
is something fundamental here.
There are some ideas,
from Penrose and others,
about the role of gravity
in making systems classical.
But we don't know.
So I'm going to finish
my talk, essentially
like most of the talks
have been finished,
by a big question mark.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is pretty much
always the same in physics.
You always answer
some questions,
and open more problems,
more questions.
But I'm not completely
finished, because I
was told that I should also try
to summarize a little bit what
we have all learned.
So it's two minutes.
More or less.
He's trying to kick me out.
[LAUGHTER]
So what have we learned?
And again, Einstein
comes to the rescue.
Einstein said so many
very profound things.
And one of the things he
said is that "no amount
of experimentation can
ever prove me right,
but a single experiment
can prove me wrong."
And we had one example of that,
with this blackbody radiation.
People did all
these experiments--
Maxwell was great-- the view,
the wave nature of light
was perfect.
But there was this one
experiment that didn't fit,
and it changed everything.
It forced people to
invent quantum mechanics,
this new view of
reality and all that.
So this is absolutely
true and profound,
that one experiment can force
you to revisit everything.
And this is exactly those
experiments that we like.
And this is why people will
do LHC, to push the limits.
This is why people do
gravitational wave detection.
This is the motivation,
to push the theories,
to push until we have
a place where it fails.
Because that's-- when it fails--
that we can hopefully learn
something fundamentally new.
Now, I should say that this
is not always an easy job.
It can be quite
humbling, because we
have our preconceived
view of things,
and we have to change it.
And my son, who is
a very wise man,
once told me that there
are only two things
that academics don't like.
The first one is the
current situation,
and the second one is change.
[LAUGHTER]
So there we go.
OK.
So we have this problem here.
But on the other
hand, the payoff
can be quite extraordinary.
And we have seen some
of this payoff today,
and in the other
lectures as well.
So this unknown, and in being
in a situation of ignorance,
is actually what
physicists strive for.
I was preparing this slide
and I was talking to my wife,
and she said, do you really
want to use the word ignorance,
because ignorance has
a bad connotation?
But it's not.
It should not be.
OK?
Ignorance is just an
excuse to understand
what we don't understand.
So ignorance, in this sense--
in this very narrow sense--
is actually what we strive to
figure out, and to clear up.
This is really what
keeps us going.
And this is why I think
there is no better job.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]